in the opening scene we are introduced
to an arrogant bollywood music producer
shakti kumar he is judging a children's
singing competition with a fellow singer
when she gives points to a kid for being
cute shakti flips out and starts cursing
her he makes the kid cry commenting that
his cuteness isn't a talent this causes
a huge scandal and shakti is boycotted
from the singers association the
protagonist of the film is a 15 year old
girl named insea living with her muslim
family in the city of baroda her family
consists of her father farook mother
najma and her little brother guru farooq
beats his wife for the smallest mistakes
and is abusive to insea as well one day
insea returns from a school trip and
sees her mother wearing sunglasses when
they are alone she takes them off
revealing that she has a black eye najma
dismisses it as an accident but her
daughter knows the real cause of the
bruising she sympathizes with najma and
feels helpless that she cannot do
anything to help her the mother and
daughter have a bond like no other in a
household where women are only taught to
cook and clean najma has fought for
insea's right to go to school she has
also made insea a talented singer after
gifting her a guitar when she was only
six insea's dream is to become a
professional singer but she knows as
long as her father is her guardian it
will never come true while on the train
today she was told about an inter-school
singing competition where the winner
gets a laptop she tells najma about it
and decides to ask permission from her
father when he returns home from work to
her dismay farook is in a bad mood
because najma forgot to put salt in his
curry he throws the plate in her face
and storms into his room insea refrains
from asking him about the competition
afraid to agitate him even more this has
become a routine for the family and
insea is tired of it she tells her
mother to divorce him but najma has no
money to take care of herself without
her husband the following day insia
returns home from school to see a laptop
on the table najma bought it for her
because she was the reason insea
couldn't ask her father's permission
yesterday incia celebrates by showing
her mother several things on the
internet for the next week that farooq
is away she is over the moon the laptop
brings joy to the family whose only form
of entertainment was television until
now then insea decides to make a youtube
video of herself singing but realizes
that if she shows her face her father
will find out upon seeing her frustrated
najma suggests she wear a burqa that way
the audience can focus on the song and
her father won't recognize her either
india sings an original song for her
first video and uploads it under the
name secret superstar she waits for
views to come in but they never do don't
worry insea this happens to all of us a
few days later india gives up on youtube
and continues on with her life but the
very next day she notices that more than
11 000 people have watched the video and
all of them are complimenting her voice
najma is excited for her but scared that
her husband will get a hint of this she
reminds insea to be extra careful on the
internet the next day farook returns
home from a month-long trip and sees the
laptop najma says that it was a gift to
insia from her uncle in mumbai the man
doesn't ask further questions much to
their relief a few days later he goes on
yet another trip as soon as he leaves
insea gets on her laptop and makes a
second video this time she sings a
self-written song about her mother which
goes viral within a single day she
starts getting attention from music
producers alongside gaining a lot of
followers by the end of the month her
face is in the newspaper then we are
introduced to one of insea's classmates
named chintan he has a crush on her and
has heard her sing for years one day
chintan asks her if she is the secret
superstar because he noticed that they
sound similar insea tells him everything
and begs him to keep it a secret chintan
is happy to help and is glad that she
trusts him enough to share at night
insea is going through her emails when
she sees one from a controversial
producer shakti he is struggling to find
a singer for his new song after he was
boycotted hence he asks insea to come to
mumbai to record a song for him but she
isn't interested she has heard of his
controversies and believes that he is
not the ideal person to work with at the
moment because insea's focus is diverted
she doesn't do very well on a class test
when farook finds out about this he is
furious he blames her guitar and
destroys it demanding that she never
sing again in a fit of rage insia
retaliates which makes him more
aggressive in the end najma has to
interfere so he won't hurt her daughter
the next evening everyone is getting
ready to go to a relative's wedding
farouk asks his wife to wear a gold
necklace that she was gifted long ago
but it turns out that she sold the
necklace to buy the laptop for insea she
pretends to look for it in the cupboard
and is trembling in fear insea finds out
about this and suggests they pretend
that it is lost however farook hears
them talking and discovers the truth
rage flashes in his eyes as he declares
that they won't be going to the wedding
today anser realizes her mother is in
trouble and takes the blame herself but
nothing she says stops him he slaps his
wife and orders the kids to go inside
the room insea holds gudu in her arms
and cries unable to hear her mother's
screams a while later the noise stops
and she runs outside to see her mother
on the floor but farook is still not
done with her to stop him insea throws
her laptop off the balcony and begs for
his forgiveness the mother and daughter
watch the broken laptop seeing all their
hopes and dreams crushed in front of
their eyes for the next few days they do
not talk to anyone chintan notices
insea's strange behavior and cheers her
up at school a few days later farook
returns home with sweets he reveals that
he is being transferred to riyadh in
saudi arabia and is taking the entire
family he has even arranged insea's
marriage to the son of a friend insea is
completely against moving to riyadh let
alone getting married at 15. she is
especially mad at her mother because
najma knew farooq was planning this but
she never told insea later insea is
watching the tv when she hears news
about the music producer shakti he just
divorced his wife who has the best
divorce lawyer in the country if insea
does a favor for shakti he might hook
her up with the lawyer who will help her
mother the following day she asks
chintan for his phone and calls the
producer he is ready to send her a
ticket to mumbai the next day insea is
skeptical because she has never been
away from home without her parents she
feels better when chintan promises to
arrange everything for her the next
morning she packs a burka to school and
receives the plane ticket from chintan
who has printed it out upon reaching
school they sneak out through the window
and jump off a wall insea thanks him
before running away she boards the plane
on her own for the first time in her
life at the mumbai airport a sketchy man
claims that he is there to pick her up
despite being afraid she goes with him
and reaches the studio where shakti and
his team are waiting for her he welcomes
her wholeheartedly a complete opposite
of how he is portrayed in the media
however the song he wants her to sing is
outside of her comfort zone it is an
upbeat song that has many innuendoes
where she has to moan shakti sees her
struggling and understands she is not
the one for the job but insea retaliates
she says that the song sounds like a
lewd version of a song that was supposed
to be about love shakti is shocked at
the comment because she is right he
wrote the song 10 years ago and it was
originally supposed to be a melodic r b
but since the producers nowadays want
party songs he modified the lyrics to
fit their tastes he is ready to fight
the producers if insea is willing to
sing it in its original form she agrees
and sings beautifully by the end of the
song everyone in the studio applauds her
a while later shakti is driving her to
the airport and telling her about the
payment but insu stops him saying that
she doesn't want his money but his help
she wants to meet his wife's divorce
lawyer for her mother initially shakti
doesn't want to take her to the woman
because she hates him but on seeing that
insia is desperate he arranges an
appointment for next week insea returns
home by the end of the day without
anyone suspecting her the next week she
flies to mumbai again with chintan's
help shakti brings her to the lawyer's
office insea tells her everything about
her parents and begs for help the woman
gives her a file of papers and asks her
to bring her mother's signature if she
signs them and goes to the police farouk
will be arrested from then on they can
not only sue him for violence but also
get a divorce settlement in the evening
india returns home and tells her mother
about the papers and excitement but
najma doesn't reciprocate it she is
shocked that her daughter has been
flying to a different city moreover
insea never asked najma if she wanted a
divorce just like her father never asked
her if she wanted to get married najma
feels like everyone makes decisions for
her and she doesn't own her life anymore
insea calls her mother a coward for not
speaking up for their lives she stops
talking to her positive that najma is at
fault for everything then one afternoon
insea's aunt calls her evil for
disrespecting her mother she reveals
that when najma was pregnant with her
farouk wanted to abort the baby najma
was beaten and taken to the hospital but
she ran away she only returned after 10
months with an infant in tow and
promised that if she got pregnant with a
girl again she would abort it thankfully
she did not but insea calling her a
coward could not be further away from
the truth after finding out what najma
has been through insia is ready to do
whatever she says she deletes her
youtube channel from a cyber cafe and
prepares herself to move to the new
country shakti calls her several times
and offers help he is ready to call the
police and child protective services for
her but insia has made her decision her
song is released in a few days and it
creates a sensation it charts number one
on all platforms making her an actual
celebrity najma is proud of her daughter
and is disheartened that she has to give
up on her dreams then on the last day of
school insea and shintan talk for a long
time in the end they say their last
goodbyes and separate after returning
home the family leaves for the airport
with their luggage the first flight they
have to take is to mumbai and then saudi
arabia at the mumbai airport a problem
arises because the luggage is a bit too
heavy farook orders insea to throw her
guitar away and she does as told but
then najma speaks against her husband
for the first time she says that they
should keep the guitar because it is
insia's most prized possession an
enraged farouk raises his hand but she
orders him to stop taking a long breath
she says that if he hits her she will
have no choice but to go to the police
and if he is arrested for violence he is
sure to lose his job the better option
for him would be to fly to saudi on his
own because she and her children are not
going farouk is left speechless he tries
to convince her otherwise but she brings
out the divorce papers and signs them as
she walks her kids outside he follows
her begging her to listen but in the end
they leave and he has to fly alone after
that the family goes to the national
entertainment awards where insea has
been nominated for best singer
unfortunately she doesn't win the award
but is called to the stage as an
honorary guest she gives a heartfelt
speech about her mother and the movie
ends as they hug
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel thank you for watching